I don't know if we can articulate it
it's just something you have to see you
can really see animals happier and
that's what makes it even more difficult
is when you consume them you want to
make sure that it's a person that grew
them animal the animal itself is
respected in the food that you're
cooking you want to make sure that that
cook understands that process that a
life was taken for for someone else you
know to say that it's not as valuable as
another that's for that's not for me to
decide but for my part I want to I want
us to do the best possible and I would
say almost all of our proteins that we
get are are sustainably raised we're
trying it's it's hard it's really hard
to source that out and to get it right
and to get an affordable to where you
can get you know again there's I can't
remember the book but like everything
and then everything in the world has
risen in price but the one thing that
people want to stay the same is the cost
of protein and beef and chicken but you
know you have to pay the price if it's
going to be you know grown the right way
because it's not cheap you know
there's a reason why people have eat KFC
or McDonald's and stuff like that it's
because you know if you want to eat if
you want to eat well you have to choose
where you want to eat and you know to
eat properly growing stuff is not cheap
because there's a lot of love and there
was a lot of Labor involved and their
work there's not palates given to these
birds to make it grow faster or hormones
or whatever and at the end of day you
can taste a big difference to like a
whether it's a chicken growing from
pencil from Pennsylvania on a diet of
you know milk fed pool art and it's
gonna be more delicious no question it's
gonna be more delicious than your your
run-of-the-mill supermarket chickens